let me ask you ask the audience this
question if it is even possible to limit
self dealing in a scarce world where
needs are fine where means are finite
but needs are insatiable it seems we are
caught in some kind of bad equilibrium
Wow welcome everyone hello hello hello
we get a little energy from the audience
thank you it's Friday afternoon evening
yes is so nice to see all you beautiful
people out here today thank you thank
you for coming out we're very excited
for this panel on identifying and
correcting perverse incentives we're
SuperDuper grateful for you all coming
out we're very grateful for Indy bio for
hosting us in their beautiful space
thank you Andy bio also grateful to bio
captivate yin and Lewis for partnering
with us I'm Alan Saki on the hosts of
simulation which you may have seen
before
where we interview some of the greatest
minds alive Ron Vargas is our producer
director he's back there doing our
camera for today and unfortunately for
those that may have seen that Esther and
ASA were both on the panel originally
but then s there message us with an
emergency and Aiza was sick so well
really unfortunate they weren't able to
make it but we did our best to find
replacements last minute and we're gonna
have an incredible evening together for
the last-minute changes actually Louis
has offered everyone in the audience a
free ticket to his biology is not
programming introduction to DNA RNA and
proteins course that he's going to be
teaching that date is still to be
determined but you all can reach out to
bio captivate and for attending that
event I actually have had an incredible
experience attending the first class
that Louis taught and I thought
was one of the best synthesis of biology
making it really relatable so highly
recommend that so also and we'll move to
the yet the next slide to see that the
UN Family Foundation helped they're
there and they're an incredible people
they have a book that they release
called interdependent capitalism and
make sure that everyone gets a copy of
the book on the way out it's right next
to Louis right there it's again just one
of those books that really puts it's so
well what's going on with our world with
those perverse incentives and solutions
for our way to move forward and why they
originated it in the first place as well
and they are also behind the incentive
prize on incentives and that's an
incentive competition designed to
nurture innovations that promote a
better future for all through inclusive
stake holding vested in their dependent
interests and goal congruence and that
challenge invites social innovations
from any discipline including economics
politics arts technology and sciences
including the social sciences and the
website is there then center prize on
incentives org and if you put in the
code seven one nine one nine into the
how did you hear about us field that
would help move the identify that you
found out about it through us and the
challenge runs from July 1st 2019 to
December 1st 2019 and a select number of
winners will be chosen to receive five
thousand US dollars each for the best
proposal submitted in accordance with
the terms on the website so the deadline
for submissions is October 31st so
remember from all these things that
we're going to be talking about identify
and correct perverse incentives you can
submit a proposal to the incentive prize
on incentives alright and just a couple
quick thoughts before we start this big
human experiment that's unfolding on
planet Earth is both marvelous and
fragile and there's no guarantees of the
immense amount of civilizations that
have collapsed before us that we were
able to handle the godlike technologies
that we are creating our maturity ethics
and wisdom needs to skyrocket if we plan
to make it through these challenging
times we know thanks to much of the
globalized infrastructure and incentive
systems people have been pulled out of
Burtie at unprecedented rates and
quality of life is increasing around the
world we also acknowledge that many of
these incentive systems have evolved
self-dealing tendencies embedded growth
obligations oligopoly dynamics lack of
inclusive stake holding with non
represented entities like the ecology we
all reside in and future generations who
would like to inherit a well-functioning
earth not polluted with problems we have
tools ranging from ancient wisdom to new
technologies to correct these perverse
incentives and ensure greater propensity
to make it through these challenging
times this is what our pile conversation
will be about tonight and I ask you for
a favor embody a couple words into your
essence with me the first word is nuance
and one of the if you've seen any of my
social profiles that's my middle name
now I change it to nuance purposely I'm
trying to subconsciously help people
move into non-binary thinking this
multivariate mindsets equanimity so
staying even-keel calm and composed
gratitude for life that we are even here
and there's something rather than
nothing for every breath for every drink
of water for every bite of food
gratitude for us being here together and
humility so again I welcome you extend
deep gratitude and wish you all fruitful
experience with our event so let's start
with panelist introductions again thank
you thank you everyone for coming
SuperDuper grateful all right can we all
maybe take a deep breath in together see
one more it's so nice to be present with
you all tonight all right
Poe Brunson is the first one here to my
left to your right his wide-ranging
published works have earned national
awards and best-selling titles he's a
storyteller and futurist read
conceptualism reconceptualizing complex
challenges into more elegant forms to
broaden understanding and highlight
priorities next to my left in your right
is in this Shawn Doug Narain
he's focused on climate and ocean issues
is unprecedented he founded and shared
the World Economic Forum special
initiative on oceans wrote soul of the
sea in the age of the algorithm and is
working on a new international UN treaty
on life in the oceans next up is Maya
Lockwood Maya Lockwood empowers
entrepreneurs voice
is emotional intelligence and leadership
skills she oversees and divides
communication strategy and community
building around content thought
leadership media events speaking
engagements and strategic partnerships
next up is Berkshire Sharma is a
principal at Indy bio doing analysis
market research modeling and automation
for their portfolio and data pipeline
also actively works with the portfolio
companies on building data rooms and
techno-economic modeling and last up is
Luis Metzger who is co-founder of bio
captivate and chief scientific officer
of Tierra Biosciences believing that the
precise engineering of biology will
enable a coming revolution in how humans
live work and interact with our planet
all right let's start things off by
asking you what is the most first
principle or upstream root issue with
these perverse incentives and feel free
whoever would like to start things off I
will upstream way way upstream for me
and when I spent a lot of time thinking
about is that that the material world is
visible and our internal worlds are not
necessarily visible and the net result
of this is that our status systems are
primarily based around the visible world
and it leads us to seek property money
status symbols use a lot of the world's
natural resources in a way and that we
don't have a way to essentially display
or the value of our internal states of
mind now my dear friend Maya may
remember everybody's name and I can't
remember their name she may have
incredibly wild dreams and minor
pedestrian but there's no way to have
status in us or social way around that
and and on the deepest level wait wait
so this is where very upstream right but
is this fundamental problem how can we
make people value the things that we all
individually try to value
we all individually try to reward with
each other and talk about ours being
super important but we don't have you
know you can't like I kind of said post
on Facebook like this is my dream last
night it was awesome
you be jealous of my dreams but if I buy
a condo over the ball park and I it
costs two million dollars and I post a
beautiful photo of the ballpark from the
view of my condo you can all watch and I
think that fundamental element of how to
bring our interior worlds out and more
visible is it's one dimension that's way
way upstream that I find myself thinking
about a lot thank you
that was beautiful a great place to
start I think that we need a reward
system were incentives that recognize
people who have taken a hundred percent
responsibility for their lives for their
happiness for their emotional
intelligence and I don't know if we have
anything like that yet but a hundred
percent responsibility I think I would I
would agree there and I was just
thinking about reverse incentives in how
they relate to one me being a millennial
where it feels like old people are
giving us a future we don't want and to
me being third world or global South
citizen where it seems the post-world
War two economy seems to favor developed
nations and there's this cycle of
emerging developing that we just haven't
been able to break and I think it comes
from caring ironically how much we care
how much institutions care that has bred
a form of paternalism and I I think that
central to institutions at the family
level as well as the global loop level
so paternalism and caring ironically is
breathing perverse incentives in my mind
and just to build on this and the caring
and I know a lot of you hear of I've got
a big science background of science
focus
and so several months ago we had a
meeting in India with the Dalai Lama and
one of the challenges that we talked we
were talking about some of the big
challenges from our become science of
spirituality perspective and one of the
big challenges of climate change
oceans what's going on with our
environment and we asked who do you have
where do you see hope Waititi change
actually emerging in this world of you
know turmoil and turbulence and he said
well we actually he actually thinks that
we fundamentally misunderstood science
so what do you mean by that
he said well our science basis it's
still based on Darwinism you know
concept 200 years ago where you see
something very dramatic you know a lion
attacking a gazelle orca orcas attacking
a penguin so it's extremely dramatic and
it's based on survival of the fittest
and that mindset of survival of the
fittest of the natural world then
percolated down into our social systems
our political systems our economic
systems we encourage competition and
dog-eat-dog so well actually that's
based on a misunderstanding of science
and I'm sure there's a lot more
scientists over here look correctly he
said when you actually look at certain
species and genes that have actually
survived for many thousands of years
these are species that exists in herds
in shells in communities and
interdependency of different species as
well so actually when you look at
survival although you know one is very
dramatic but really talk about survival
of the kindness and as well as some of
the kindest you know can we bring about
a new age of empathy where we can
actually create this new value system
that we'd like to see so I thought that
was very powerful and profound in terms
of how do we just move beyond the you
know the last 200 years of a certain
mindset to a new paradigm of compassion
and kindness so I would see a major
upstream determinant of some of the
perverse incentives that we deal with
being this idea of a runaway objective
function so especially in the age of the
algorithm we're in a position where we
can really efficiently optimize the
extraction of resources or the creation
of wealth however one wishes to define
that and so many other
and in doing some things perhaps to
efficiently
we're undermining our future and
creating conditions where maybe we've
over optimized and this this is in so
many different fields so I think this
runaway objective function optimisation
that runs throughout modern economies
academia many other fields is is one
route one cause of perverse incentives
it seems to be that this idea that the
internal state of how one feels with
their own well-being with the family the
community in the world that that needs
some sort of a there needs to be some
sort of an incentive for us to figure
out how to make that incentivize for
people to talk about and to want to
share and also for people to rank
themselves up in terms of their own
divine a lot connection with their
purpose and with the world's trajectory
now with indigenous tribes from around
the world have for the longest time been
talking about that this first principle
issue of our disconnection from nature
from what sustains us is directly
reflected in the issues that we have in
our civilization where do you believe
that the disconnection from nature this
first principle of indigenous wisdom
lies with the issue we have with
perverse incentives well I'll take it
out of that I mean I think what's
interesting is we're starting to see
this recognition of different value
systems that exist and know in the u.s.
I know one of the Native American
cultures here talk about the
seventh-generation principle really
thinking much more longer-term and how
the seventh generation judge decisions
that are that are being made and somehow
we still have a economic system that's
based on a GDP and GDP is a very modern
concept it's only been around for 70 or
80 years post Second World War as a way
to could measure instruments and even
central banks are relatively modern
concept so I think part of the bridge is
how do we actually start harmonizing our
institutions with some of the other
value systems that we've had you know
why can that not be measures beyond GDP
value systems and institutions that link
to our value of our elders or wisdom or
the value of nature for example so I
think that those institutions will need
to be modernized in sync with some of
our
ancient cultures so I mean one one thing
that I think is the indigenous people
knew and know that many modern societies
partially forgotten is the value of
what's evolved in deep time and nature
and if you think about green chemistry
or you actually many of the
pharmaceuticals that you all probably
have used maybe they've even saved your
life
because they were an antibiotic and you
would have died of sepsis if they had it
not you know been for that treatment
these are natural products lots of them
are natural products so that means that
they're made by enzymes encoded by DNA
in organisms and you know plants
bacteria fungi all organisms all
different types of organisms in nature
and I think that looking back towards
what's in nature for an added value of
species diversity and and a value beyond
ecotourism in terms of preserving
beautiful and diverse ecosystems is
something that we learn from from
indigenous cultures and you know the
field of natural product chemistry is
quite dependent it has been quite
dependent on indigenous wisdom and in
fact many of their medical interventions
have been borne out by solid science so
I think that that's that's one thing
that in my field I think a lot about
well two thoughts on on this one relates
to property and fundamentally like today
I was talking and someone was asking me
do you think biotech is
like IIT startups and and I said no you
know it's not the next this next decade
is not the same and the most fundamental
difference is IP in the software and
Internet world you maybe have IP on your
algorithms and some of your chipset
designs and this and that but people
basically just move fast it really fast
don't care not that big of a deal you
don't really corner a market because you
have IP and biotech you do and in fact
if you're a biotech startup you have to
be very nimble around other people's IP
to try to figure out how to move forward
and take out a market in fact and it's
necessary oddly necessary you know for
our hundred and five companies that
we've graduated so far virtually all of
them had IP and if they didn't we
couldn't have funded them and they
couldn't have gotten follow-on funding
from other Metro was necessary to
extract these amazing solutions for
human planetary health out of this sort
of idea stage in the research station to
commercialize them so it's necessary but
it's also sort of tragic because this
fundamental element of property and
defending property means that even for a
lot of the solutions we'd want in the
world people literally owned them and
owned the right to use those and on them
certainly use them in a commercial
entities for a commercial venue reminded
of that Abraham Maslow before he created
his famous sort of triangle of hierarchy
of needs he was sort of working on and
this idea of it he went to visit a
friend who wasn't ethnologist and
anthropologist studying the Blackfoot
Indians in Canada and he went there and
he they had their own sort of triangle
of needs but he kind of inverted it and
so what he took is our sort of Western
idea of a hierarchy and easy simply lis
inverted it and what's really clear
there where we think of this idea of
respecting your elders or hanging on to
what your elders knew like we we have
this sort of mysticism around that
concept but in fact if you think of it
like more like they're at the level like
your elders taught you eat this bush
don't eat that one
it'll kill you this is how you catch a
fish not like that you'll die like don't
eat that it looks yummy but it's not
good for you you had it was a matter of
when we say existential threat it was an
existential threat
there was no books there was no
Wikipedia there was no Nature Reserve to
store all this information you literally
had to remember what your elders told
you or you would die and that we've
missed aside that but not really
understood that when we basically
learned to record information and pass
that on by other means we didn't have to
it wasn't an existential threat anymore
to pay attention to what your elders
said and today we think of existential
not even as a threat to our existence
but almost the opposite like I don't
have any threats to my existences and
therefore I'm kind of drifting in the
world my purpose and we've sort of
inverted it just as much as as Maslow
did and how we think about these things
and so I think fundamentally a lot even
just like recording of information
itself would arguably have changed that
paradigm you didn't have to listen your
elders if I could go look it up on
Wikipedia where I than ask and Dad
remember what he said going back to
nature I think we will have to
reclassify this divide between urban and
nature our urban spaces and natural
spaces I should say because most of
humanity as we know it is going to live
in cities and you know one maybe maybe
dreads are moving there but also we have
this deep yearning to be out of the
massive concrete jungles - yeah and I
think again going going back to this
idea of the love of nature and
appreciation of its mystical beauty or
this romantic ization if you look at
most tribes or primal cultures today
they they are living in this hybrid
urban-rural dichotomy where they're very
disengaged
from the aesthetic value of nature I I
think of Indian shrines where there's so
much plastic around it and actually at
me I'm from them from the Himalayas and
once I went on a hike where the temple
groundskeeper said that they don't care
about the plastic because they're
disengaged from the aesthetics of the
plastic and I also think about birds
that are more successful in urban
environments as predators because
there's just so much food out here then
then birds that live in bushes so just
rethinking our environment and this
urban nature divide I think is is is
very important and and you know just
disengaging the aesthetics is is also
very very very important to if we are to
identify this perverse incentive it's my
take somewhere down to the use value
versus the exchange value of things we
have to deconstruct it more I don't I
don't claim to have an answer but yeah I
think that's that's part of the problem
here oh yeah
thoughts as well on indigenous wisdom
well just one thing comes to mind and
that is that we don't have initiation
rites to become ill to become adults and
so a lot of indigenous cultures they do
have those ceremonies in which they are
strongly rooted in nature that help
people become and they learned that from
their elders as well communities are
involved and we are disconnected from
each other from our communities from our
families and therefore we're also
connected disconnected from nature yeah
it's like third graders with godlike
technologies we haven't initiated
ourselves into the deepest spiritual
wisdom that they know and yet we get to
play with the technologies that are
being democratized in the hands of
everyone on the planet that have so much
power now yeah um what is the best
for identifying the perverse incentives
I don't know Lois come on you've moved a
lot of this one
all right well to put it simply I think
one could get a good start by following
the money and not that money is bad but
I do think you know I really think that
pose comments earlier about how does one
signal one's in or wealth and how did
groups of people signal their collective
additive or multiplicative wealth of
their you know minds and passions about
things they're trying to create and it's
different than then accruing money it's
but not incompatible but I think that
I'll give you an example so I like to
use the example of universities and I've
seen some bad things happen in research
universities and in how big academic
research is is funded and conducted and
again it's not all black and white but
there are big perverse incentives there
and if you follow the money you will see
those perverse incentives so long as
graduate students and postdoctoral
trainees are cheaper than robots they're
going to be transferring small volumes
of clear liquids into other small
volumes of clear liquids and learning
not very much from that you know it's 95
percent prep time five percent
collecting real data and thinking about
it and so there is a perverse incentive
grants have large overheads taken by
universities so for instance University
acts will get a grant or a professor at
University X will get a grant for a
million dollars for basic research 500k
of that is typically taken off the top
by the university ostensibly to keep the
lights on but then once use a
proliferation of assistant associate
deputy Dean's of this or that and you
know an other wastage that really
doesn't have to do with education and
you can see how grant harvesting and
turning turning the other way when
when data are used to obtain grants is
something that's incentivized so that's
that's one example but you know you
follow the money and you you can see in
that in many other cases well I was
thinking along the same lines I don't
know how the comb fight for the right
word for it which is this sort of you
know beware the nobility of first
appearances and the way that
universities fund themselves on by
taking half of or half again of each
every grant is is sort of the NIH gives
thirty nine billion dollars every year
to our universities to do science work
it's really important it drives
everything and all the solutions that we
need it's fantastic but there are these
sort of things you wouldn't see until
you look at it you know I was very
excited when with the US we created the
forty five Q carbon sequestration Tax
Credit $50 for sequestering a ton $35
for just capturing but then I looked up
whose the actual number one user of this
and it's the petranova facility in
Houston where the hua Parrish boiler
number eight burns coal and they're so
they're coal burning they capture it
good for them they pipe it 82 miles east
into Louisiana where they use it as
fracking the new fracking material to
push up yet more oil so the the oilfield
there which was doing something like
3,000 3,500 ninety million dollar grant
to build this build the whole
sequestration and pipeline facility so
the nobility of it is fantastic right
like it's a great thing that you'll go
look at the number one user and I don't
even know if it's good or bad dish on me
to help me out here but like it doesn't
feel like that was the outcome we wanted
to to create yet more fossil fuel
extraction with it I don't know if they
were extremely cunning or they planned
this in advance or what it is but it is
there's def
a sort of a you know
beware the wolf in sheep's clothing
I was actually before you sent money
it's good you reminded me I was thinking
of data but now that we have money I'll
add to that B we don't have to think
about money per se rather the time value
of money I think a perverse in the time
value of money capitalism as its set up
works between five to 25 years
discounted cash flows and interest rates
work only work between five to twenty
that's when they're meaningless and if
you look at capitalism today or
globalization today we have not
reconciled our past we are thinking of
universal basic income to offset future
inequality but we don't think about how
that stems from historic inequality
right and so thinking about time value
of money is I think very very important
something we are very bad at and
something we have not thought of and I
have only learned working at a VC firm
where there's this concept of a cap
table or a capitalization table which is
the spreadsheet of who owns how much
overtime and at any buyer we have a
saying we will only fund a company with
a clean cap table so we're the skin in
the game from the day and ideas taught
off till the day someone is funded is
proportionate to effort and it seems the
world is being investing on a faulty cap
table and you know capitalists have
figured it out no one in the valley
funds a start-up with a faulty cap table
if the history of your startup and
effort and talent is disproportionate
you're not funded but global trade has
it been carried out has blood has a very
very gruesome past that we don't talk
about so we've been funding our world on
a faulty cap table so that that's that's
what I would say time value of money is
something I want to learn more about
and I'm sure some of the audience member
that was looking at how they probably
have some views on perverse incentives
and how does that I could actually
contributes a bit you know my two cents
worth Basel have workshop time to do
that yes so I think talent is a good
indicator you know when you look at the
top of organizations whether it's a
public sector the private sector you
wonder whether this the talent at the
top level really reflects and the talent
in society is it a fair representation
on every Petric that we look at of of
society and you know link to that the
other point is around certain
stereotypes in terms of you know
challenging set of assumptions I think
so in one of my roles I map advises a
Chinese government on on their ocean and
climate strategies one of three
foreigners in in that capacity and
what's interesting is right now yeah we
talked about fracking you talk about you
know the US and historically has been
Western nations it's been Europe it's
been the US Canada Australia who's been
leading the charge around environmental
stewardship but the scale of what we're
facing with climate change is so acute
you know within 12 years we hit these
tipping points and I'm from a small
island called Mauritius in the Indian
Ocean I've just come back this week that
it's devastating I mean when I look at
that I was around some of the reefs
which are which are most pristine marine
parks we used to have one of the largest
brain corals in the world probably the
size of this this run only 2% is alive
today and ten years ago this was a
vibrant full of color so even in the
country that I'm from in 12 years we're
gonna hit that tipping point where I
will not have any coral reefs and that's
a third of my GDP you know protection of
our coastlines our hotel sectors so this
is a very existential crisis I'm sure if
the US had a third of its GDP at risk
there'll be a lot more activity than
building fracking stations and so what's
interesting is you know what is the role
of democracy on this and we're finding
countries like the u.s. obviously
everyone's followed what's happening
politically here like the UK like Europe
democratic countries are not moving as
fast as I need to on some of the big
challenges
and so one of the really important
questions we've got to put on the table
is are there gonna be transition are we
going to naturally progress to a cleaner
world using market mechanisms using
democracy or would there be another
mechanism to do that and what's
interesting that China is that China is
a very large B they're building the
Bolton Road initiative that will touch
no sixty percent of global GDP a third
of the world's population over 68
countries for better or for worse and
yet they're moving a lot more
aggressively than Europe or the US in
terms of climate and environmental
standards and so that I think it's
something that we'll have to grapple
with at some stage what are the
trade-offs in values but at least on one
metric on the environmental side well
there's a lot of stereotype in the US
media when you actually go to China and
see the progress that's been happening
almost on a quarterly basis it is
actually very profound so I think that's
something just to be aware of as well
okay and then I'm curious on like which
if when you think about things as code
which is which which which governments
and which organizations and which
companies around the world are running
the best code to be stewards of the
planet how do we take that and build on
top of that what do we do to correct
self-dealing institutions and increase
kin altruism
so the self-dealing institution and its
really well explained in the unified way
foundations interdependent capitalism
the self dealing can be thought of like
when in the days of the kin tribe as
Paul was explaining to you with his
incredible humor as well that you would
tell a story to someone else for the
benefit of the other person because you
would want to make sure they don't die
eating the wrong thing nowadays you have
all of the propaganda that's occurring
with food self dealing food company self
dealing physician self dealing everybody
in so many ways and so what they're
doing is they're
just propagating a meme to try and earn
more money for themselves instead of
something that's actually helpful to you
so how do we how do we correct those
self-dealing institutions and also how
do we increase kin altruism across the
global scale yes ma'am
well I think June would say the media is
a good place to start and the
storytelling that we choose to share so
if you're talking about how say for
example a food company pedals their
product to people you want to start
telling the story of truth and whether
it does contain the things that it does
contain and that's you know it's it's it
comes down to the narrative oh don't
look at me man I don't know the answer
to this one I mean this is really I mean
I know I live in this world and I've
been a member of the media for a long
time and I other than like trying to be
honest and tell it like it is I don't I
see I see the same problem today there's
I mean every organization is a media
company and they put out a message that
makes them look good
and there's not one that doesn't do it
not one and maybe they write some you
know occasional maiya couples or
whatever and apologies but usually not
and and and your to your point like it's
one thing that you lobbyists know you
don't even lobbyists you just you know
put out your message and spend it I
don't I don't have the answer to it I
really don't I wish you did but do you
guys have answers for it yeah I mean I
will say that it's it sounds easier than
you think because every and we often do
this as truth and fake or as science and
anti science but every scientific
breakthrough fundamentally is anti
science it is violating what scientists
thought was possible and it is approving
that what they thought was impossible is
possible
so when people make scientific
breakthroughs there a lot of people read
it and thank God see science didn't know
all that thought it did and so every
scientific breakthrough they're
happening more and more more continues
to emphasize this message was a science
thought they know what they're doing but
they're actually doing what they're
doing and so it fundament crisis
psychological landscape where it's up
for grabs and so it's not as simple as
as people think you know downstairs we
graduate 11 15 companies every time and
they're doing something people thought
was impossible that the NIH wouldn't
give them a grant cuz you can't possibly
do that that doesn't this is gonna break
the laws of physics they would say and
then it turns out to be true possible so
when you're living with that is at one
end of the spectrum as a problem I don't
know how you define the difference
between stuff we think is good and Noble
and stuff that shouldn't exist I don't
I'm not sure we have to follow that but
I do you think on the self-serving
institutions I think what we know one of
the questions we face it kind of when
spectrum we're going to be so in your
point about you know is every
organization a media organization there
is certain power towards transparency
and truth and for the longest time it
was the media and with a broker and now
we're obviously in this era of you know
Twitter or Facebook so the lowest common
denominator so do we rely on the madness
or the wisdom of the crowds and mob role
to actually make decisions whether
you're private or public organizations
or do the other end do you need these
these mandarins of kind of technical
experts actually making judgments for us
or is there some kind of halfway house
and how do you decide whether halfway
houses I think that's at the core of
what the question is and I don't I I
certainly don't have a good answer to
that but I think you know economics
tells us as infinite once and you know
finite needs and so or finite resources
and so you know if it's if everything is
decentralized to everybody to express in
their opinions we're never going to
truly I know Peter Diamandis talks a lot
about abundance and this year
abundance but are we are we ever gonna
meet everybody's needs and so yahoo has
that mechanism to actually control who
gets what in a redistribution I think
that's a key question but you know Trust
is gonna be absolutely core to so I'm
the subject of self dealing how to
combat self dealing again I'll go back
to the example of funding of academic
research well and and corporate research
through government academic corporate
sort of three you know corner triangular
funding approaches the problem I think
and what is regulatory capture so if you
look at NIH study sections the panels of
people who review grants to the National
Institute of Health they're
disproportionately professors they're
disproportionately high-ranking
long-serving professors and not
surprisingly such professors have the
highest rates of funding of their own
grants and so it's it's easy to look at
someone's nascent research program and
say well that's not established compared
to my own you know I'm not you know I'm
not going to fund that but you know
professor or XYZ you know down the hall
for me has 50 grad students and 20
postdocs and cranks out papers you know
that research is more precedented and
more fundable more you know more
achievable and so i think that the
solution to this is is not to remove
senior professors from study sections
but it's to supplement those study
sections with people with other
perspectives and i would go so far as to
put research trainees as some at some
percentage on study sections because
they their lives are in many ways
affected by these grants being funded
and so if you're going to bring in all
the stakeholders to make this more
sustainable i think you should bring in
all the stakeholders to some extent and
so i'd like to see to sum it up you know
us moving from regulatory capture to an
expansion of regulatory responsibility
again I I have no solutions here but I
would echo what Nissan brought up this
concept of scarcity and self-dealing is
the best response to scarcity if someone
tells me Bank of America has a million
left I am going to run the Bank of
America and everyone should run for Bank
of America do towards Bank of America
it's a negative D stable equilibrium and
as long as I would let me ask you ask
the audience this question if it is even
possible to limit dealing in a scarce
world where needs are fine where means
are finite but needs are insatiable it
seems we are caught in some kind of bad
equilibrium and we know the answer to a
bank run is to tax people ironically not
the banks for the people so let's let's
think in the framework of where there
exists scarcity and where can we
eliminate this and who we tax for what
purpose to eliminate this best response
because I'm currently and that's the
only thing I can think of is if scarce
then safeguard yourself so you know that
that scarcity is central to me and I
just want to even see if there can be
ever no scarcities is what I'm wondering
my thoughts on this topic
and how about we talked about this a
little bit but we have this massive
economic machinery that is continuing to
just churn and churn and churn on a
daily basis we created a beast that
doesn't have a pause button and it also
doesn't have a recalibrate trade with a
little rudder to help us recalibrate it
in a different direction and so this
machinery continues to move so it seems
as though the it's to find new markers
for flourishing new markers for
wellbeing new markers for figuring out
how well someone's doing on the internal
how well they're doing with nature what
are some of these new markers of the
future and how do we measure them how do
we make them comment around our world I
think you're the biggest challenges of
our time if we look at the next 30 years
is how does the middle income countries
progress because if everybody aspires
you know India China Indonesia Brazil
aspires to a European Union or a u.s.
standard of living at 30,000 or 40,000
dollars per capita we burn through four
times our planetary resources and that's
a challenge within the next three
decades and if you think about the 1950s
in the u.s. the American dream you know
be the mod cons of the refrigerator the
microwave the the suburban car and a
commute that's still permeating on
televisions in mass media around the
world do you know whether you watch
Bollywood or Chinese TV or Indonesian TV
we haven't yet defined what that the
China dream is or the India dream of the
Brazil dream and that's going to be
absolutely core as a marker for what our
new economic system should look like now
can we look at an economic system that's
dependent more on access rather than
consumption you know should we be
consuming there it's also ironic you
know timer we talk about scarcity in
certain planets we have this obesity
crisis in the Western world
so there's clear discrepancies in our
economic systems in the US and and
Europe though the wealthy world versus
the global south so how do we define the
new dream for a you know if you're a 16
year old in
Indonesia today or in China today what
does that thirty-five-year-old you know
life look like for them how in terms of
children lifestyle whether consumption
and what does that look like a twenty
thousand dollars per capita measure that
hasn't yet been defined so that's I
think the center part of your question
what we need to look for so that's
really because I was going to say lower
quartiles income growth and just like
late last night two in the morning I was
looking at news saying oh you know wage
growth is over three percent again
finally it's going up and I sort of like
I got a look at this by the quartiles
and it's a different story you see that
in the top quartile wage growth is
terrific and other quartiles it is going
up but it's gone from Leon 1.2 1.3
percent annually to like 1.6 was you
school in the right direction but what
you're telling me is Sean and I don't
want the audience to miss this you've
told me this before but actually is it
is that if all those people do better
the net result is we run out of
resources four times over and therefore
it's not about sort of on some level the
desire to raise the standard of living
for all is fundamentally up against a
constraint around resources and how we
use them and not that we couldn't come
up with future technologies living
buildings made from coral that grow
themselves where everything is
sustainable and and we we use our
resources not necessarily the mass but
it's the way we're using them today that
makes that so incredibly impossible even
to even to desire for the world yeah
that's fascinating I there was a way
that we could identify how emotional and
mental freedom can be captured and
defined
and how there are so many well a
tremendous amount of people on this
planet today who are living with
generational trauma and how we can heal
that generational trauma and identify
that we've healed that successfully I
don't know how that's articulated or
defined I think that's a great point not
not just trauma but also generational
aspiration
so do going back to depot any shots
point a deli boy today dreams of a
naughty while my friends in Frankfort go
to yoga class cook Indian food and ride
their bikes to work and it's is this
dreams of a generation which they
thought were possible that will not be
satiated right if the world has to be
sustainable and going back to trauma
going back to our past huh how do we
create an emotional baseline for our
generation for our previous generation
it was I would say the abolition of
slavery was a defining baseline that set
the bit that was undeniable to everyone
what would that look like for our
generation is is something I invite that
because if it weren't for that I would
be more issues of working on a D farm
and I wouldn't be sitting in this room
right so there has to be a baseline and
I just don't know what that is so
emotions are a big part of it so thank
you my ring that up so in terms of a
hallmark of our times or the changing
hallmark of our times might be I think a
true you know transitioning from
short-termism
to a greater appreciation of the long
term it will just timescales in general
when you need to accomplish big goals
and I mean obviously we have so many
large objectives as a species ahead of
us if we wish to survive in some comfort
but I think a lot of what ills us right
now is
the quarterly quarterly financial report
and you know there's one example but
this short-term incentivization and a
great example of that is the
pharmaceutical industry and I'm leaving
aside for the moment manufacturing
generic pharmaceuticals but if you if
you look at pharma companies that are
doing basic research discovery so they
go from first concept to you know
through the whole development or
discovery and development pipeline to
bring you know small molecules or
antibodies of therapeutic value to the
market and now of course we're seeing
even engineered cells and and this is
great I mean this the work is good the
problem is the scientists don't run
those companies the accountants run
those companies or the development
executives and so programs that took 15
or 20 years to build and are close to
bearing fruit in say the area of
infectious diseases multi drug-resistant
bacteria the plug can be pulled on them
for short term financial incentives and
what was lost is it's not even
calculable and so I think that to
achieve to solve difficult problems I
see evidence in what's written in in the
in the mass media even that people are
beginning to rubella gainst this
excessive short-termism
and so I hope that a sign of our times
is people collectively in all different
areas and science to thinking about okay
I can make I can contribute part of a
20-year experiment or a 20-year series
of experiments and developments that
will make the world better and and
that's that's a that's a good use of my
time and effort I don't care about
quarterly profits so and let's let's
wrap on this question which is this is
actually really close to the heart at
Indy bio a huge fan of this 50 years
from now what will the kids say I can't
believe you were [ __ ] doing that and
for example at anybody that's so close
to my heart is the billions of animals
that
we're slaughtering on the planet for
food when we're pursuing growing meat
and bioreactors in our future another
example are these gorgeous coral reefs
around the planet
there are under destruction Maya as well
with how I can't believe you weren't
mapping your mental states I can't
believe you're just self dealing
pharmaceuticals into people's throats so
I'm really curious 50 years from now
what will the kids be saying I can't
believe you were looking doing that
letting the North Pole burn you mean I
so I could say things like I can't
believe that you used to try to treat
people's brains without looking at their
brains but I will just caution that I
don't believe we can even whether you
look a linear or exponential model to
predict the future that is going to work
out like that one of the things is that
all of the unseen unknown undiscovered
technologies that nobody has seen none
of us on the panel have seen or even
thought of on how they will disrupt
things will come to bear to change
things as well as economic systems
hopefully and you know I like to say I
bent in my years before coming into bio
I was doing futurism helping corporate
venture at times and doing some
sustainability work and I would I was
doing a lot of lucid dreaming and I
would get up in the morning and then go
back to sleep and I would play this game
of chess set in the year 2030 and there
were five players so five player chess
and one player was climate change and
one was AI and inequality and one was
genomics revolution and one was China
and one was savage in income inequality
and I would try to play out what was
going to happen I was desperate to try
to figure out the future
and coming here and being with Arvind
and it was surprising that Indy bio I
found out that I can come in as strategy
director because actually they haven't
been planning for all of that they're
they're really focused on experimenting
and reacting very very fast finding what
works and what doesn't work and funding
the ones that work and keep going and it
came out to me in this phrase which is I
just understand that hunger for a plan
but that I ended up saying to seize this
opportunity
there is no plan just a way there is no
plan just a way and that if you pursue
the way you will end up with what in
retrospect was a good plan if you try to
plan your way through all this unknown
there's no way that plan is gonna work
so in terms of the values I think it's
interesting what you said about
vegetarianism and that value so I think
some of you may have heard me speak
before we've talked in a modern era
about for the for industrial revolutions
and when the you know forth modern
Industrial Revolution right now and if
you think about the industrial
revolutions they weren't about the
widgets and the gadgets as we move from
kind of steam or wind to steam steam to
oil it was about the institutions and
the value systems that pervaded
ourselves at a time so if you think
about the 1750s to the 1850s that was an
era of colonialism of empire the time of
kind of conquest of the East Africa of
Latin America and so your value systems
like slavery was prevalent at a time it
took an act of leadership around the
1850s around the world in order to bring
about an end of slavery and in many
regions of the world in the British
French version obviously in the US as
well and then if you look from the 1850s
to the 1950s that next Industrial
Revolution as we we moved into the the
20th century we had the horrors of the
two world wars
you know the firstly the failed League
of Nations and the United Nations
Eleanor Roosevelt with the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights after the
horrors of the Holocaust but that again
brought the world together around a
certain set of values and so those
values kind of pervaded and
as we move from the 1950s through to the
2000 that third Industrial Revolution as
the oil multinationals start to expand
that was the first time the satellite
era started so in 1968 and we're gonna
celebrate Apollo 11 soon but 1968
Earthrise the first time a satellite
left Earth orbit took an image of the
earth and that was the birth of the
modern environmental movement you know
WWF was created in 1968 Greenpeace 1972
a lot of the environmental movement
Rachel Carson's Silent Spring came out
in the around that era as well so that
value systems around the environment
came about and we started bringing about
legislation to protect whaling for
example to prevent DDT yeah and so that
has taken us up to this point and so as
we look now and say okay for the next 50
years a fourth Industrial Revolution is
the era of could have biological
advancement you know digital advanced
robotics new materials what's going to
bring about a consensus we're already
seeing a consensus around plastics and
around environment we're seeing a broad
consistence consensus around around
climate I think there are some of our
institutions are already being
challenged our democratic institutions
so I think you're right that when you
look at this the question is is this
something that's gonna be created
centrally or will there be technologies
that we develop that could actually
shift our value systems in ways that we
cannot expect today so just as the
satellite took that image of the earth
had know the name of the astronaut it
took me one of you guys will remember
the astronaut who took the image of
Earth in 1968 but there no idea that
that was going to lead to a profound
environmental movement in the same way
that we've seen you know those who
fought against Chairman square or summer
declarations
that have been made how this has had a
profound impact so it could actually be
technology that shifts our value system
in a most profound way in ways that we
can't I can't assess today so that could
be where your hope would lie I hope that
in 50 years the children will say I
can't believe you didn't listen to
nature I
believe you didn't tune in and see what
was going on around you and I actually
believe that nature in speaking now and
we're going to be seeing a lot more of
her intelligence as we progress as some
of the indigenous tribes even say it's
having an allergic reaction right now to
the humans yeah I I would hope that in
the next children and then 50 years from
now would look back and be really
shocked how Jen we are so gendered and
we have we are not safeguarding rights
of people that don't fit into binary
genders and sexualities norms so I
really do hope personally there there's
a shift away from that and and children
are disgusted by how we treat some
genders and norms set around gender and
sexuality still it is 2019 yeah looking
at this question I mean there's so many
potential answers but the one that that
came to mind was I think children are
going to wonder why we allowed ourselves
to be so digitally manipulated and I
don't mean digitally as in fingers
digits but you know electronically
digitally but oh that was bad well in a
way but the well may be both but I think
that that that we are thinking is
fragmented and I'm guilty of this too I
mean I think many of us experience this
Iran you're on your corporate email at
strange hours of the night
because you sleep with your phone
because it also has an alarm clock
function and you know you have you know
slack and an other message you know apps
and and it's convenient I mean it
certainly helps things but I think we
immensely overuse it and I think it's
it's bad for areas like science like
policymaking you need time to
free-associate I think and and and bring
together disparate you know viewpoints
but also disparate pieces of information
in your mind and
you're interrupted every few seconds by
your watch vibrating on your Lu wrist
telling you that someone posted
something on Instagram or you know you
have an email from your boss at 2:30 in
the morning you know this this is not
conducive to good thinking and I think
that we don't need just good thinking
among leaders we need good quality
thinking among all of the people on
earth people need to be able to think
deeply about important issues and not be
so distracted and so when I look at what
our descendants will say if we have any
which hopefully we will is why did they
let themselves be so distracted and and
and moreover distracted to generate
profit for some companies that say that
they're helping humanity but really
aren't so in because a zoo wasn't able
to join us in the Center for humane
technology will speak on behalf of one
of their main pillars of ethos which is
that if you take these institutions that
have these business plans that are in
the form of self dealing as much of your
attention onto the device as possible
they're trained on billions of
psychometric profiles of people from
around the world and that sort of
computing power targeted at your face it
we need to humble ourselves and turn off
our notifications turn off our our
ringers and take these long periods of
time like the geniuses did in the past
to just free associate in nature all
these different types of things so this
has been such a beautiful conversation
thank you everyone for joining us on the
panel thank you our audience will have a
Q&A portion now let's get a round of
applause whoo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]